good morning to you now i have indeed
i've done a little bit of digging around
it would appear this company um
and the man behind this company has been
investigated
um by some of my colleagues actually in
the past
they've they've come back with this
response
um they say that they've looked into the
correspondence with you
and that you seemed very happy with the
courses
she gave us good reviews and even wanted
to join our crew
so we're not quite sure why she suddenly
changed her mind
other than jumping on the back of a
well-publicized
trolling campaign against us
the reality is they say over 90 percent
of our clients
give us a score of 7 out of 10 or above
for all of our courses provided to an
independent feedback company glad
not only provided reviews they've sent
me a couple of the reviews that you've
left them
but she also left a video review
um they say we trust this evidence will
speak for itself
so just a couple of things i just wanted
to talk to you about glad i mean is it
true that you wanted to
join their team yes when i
first started the uh the training
i felt i would learn even more so
if i am in the team that means i i would
have a
well i'm helping i'll learn a lot more i
really
but that doesn't make it but forgive me
that doesn't make any sense to me claire
surely if you've paid a a company to
teach you something
then all you want is to be taught
because i i wanted to learn more i felt
if i
joined the crew i'll learn a lot more so
can i but the only thing is and the
company the company have sent me the
video that you did
which seems to be you i've got a little
clip of it i'm going to play
it seems to be a video of you telling
everyone else on the internet
how wonderful this company is and how
other people
should also hand over their money and
join this this course just just
let me remind you of something you say
guys
thank you so much just the knowledge
because now i go places when i
view their houses i know exactly what
you look out for
you're talking in this video as if
you've now been educated and you've now
got the
the knowledge and as a result you're now
making a success of your life
and you're in this video telling other
people that they should also
go along with this course yeah because
that's the way i believe that i was
going to
i was going to go forward and and it was
account
accountability uh lifting each other up
because
they've been it at that moment i could
hear some people talking negative
and i was like come on we can do this i
i am going to learn more and there's so
much more
that i i am learning and i'm going to do
so much more
and then now i realized that i was not
going to get anywhere
it's 10 days 10 days for
that 9 000 and i have an head from them
and he's
beginning i don't understand
you forget forgive me if i'm missing
something
i don't understand what you're talking
about because in the video
your just talking about how this course
has been wonderful for you
it's given you the the knowledge to be
able to
to do all these successful things and
and how wonderful it is
why would you do a video like that even
if you were enjoying the course and you
were listening to some other people moan
about
it i don't understand why you would do
that and say to the organizers i want to
join your crew
i just don't understand why you do that
they think
there's not much more really i have
learned apart from me
or what i could name before but why
would you then do a video
telling other people to get some way but
why would you do a video then
talking about because the company i'll
be honest with you they they've simply
come back to me and said
this woman left us good reviews she's
even done a video talking about how
wonderful the course is and how much
she's learned and how other people
should also join this course
and and they're saying that the next
part of their email they say
sadly the trolls are encouraging people
to claim refunds
in this manner without just cause and
they're suggesting that you're just
jumping on the bandwagon trying to get
your money back when in fact you
up until that point was saying how much
you enjoyed the course and how much you
learned from it
yeah that that that's in the beginning
that's how i failed
they're now suggesting that this is
evidence that you're just trying to get
your money back even though you were
delighted with what you received
oh and it's something else
okay if it is that way then what 10 days
be in the 9 000. if you were to let's
say you were to take them to court
they would simply arrive in the court
with the
written reviews you left them saying you
were really happy with the cause
they're going to show the judge the
video of you saying how wonderful it was
and how much you've learned
and how it uh given you the keys to
unlock your potential as a property
investor
and they're going to say we don't
understand why this woman wants her
money back
she was delighted with the course
originally here's the evidence to show
it
hmm you know and it's going to be very
difficult for you to argue with that
isn't it
yeah the the whole way you're talking
just sounds very weird to me
i don't i just don't think there's very
much more you can do because
the evidence they've given me yeah no
that's all right thank you so much and
unfortunately
you're not kind of i was hoping you'd
come back with something else but
it sounds as if what i've actually done
is is just hit the nail on the head
really and you've realized it
[Music]
so yes that's it thank you so much sorry
glad
oh dear if you want to comment on that
case or if you have your own consumer
nightmare oh
you